(gentle instrumental music)
- At this point right now,
we've just finished the filling process,
and that drug product is coming over to us
in order to be packed out
into a shipping configuration
so that we can ship it to
the downstream medical.
- [Jared] After Merck's
two experimental vaccines
failed in testing, the drug maker decided
to play a different role in the pandemic,
helping rival Johnson and Johnson scale up
its vaccine manufacturing efforts.
- That really created a nice
opportunity for us to start
a collaboration with Johnson and Johnson,
and be able to leverage
their COVID vaccine product
and be able to add capacity
by leveraging our line in our team.
- [Jared] Kim Dezura is the plant manager
at Merck's vaccine manufacturing facility
in West Point, Pennsylvania.
Her plant produces at least 500,000 doses
of the Johnson and Johnson
COVID vaccine every day.
And this month J&J released
the first Merck-made shots
for distribution from
Europe to other countries.
- We're right now on the
manufacturing part of the campus.
- And it has its own zip code, is that?
- It does, it does have its own zip code.
- Public health experts
consider the J&J vaccine
key to protecting underserved
communities around the world.
The J&J vaccine only requires one dose
and can be refrigerated,
unlike the Pfizer and Moderna vaccines,
which need to be stored
at lower temperatures.
So, how did Merck's West Point plant
prepare for this immense operation?
We got an exclusive behind the scenes look
at what it takes to
manufacture the J&J vaccine.
So, what's actually
happening here at this plant?
- The relationship between
Johnson and Johnson
and Merck have really, two two parts.
So, we'll be manufacturing,
the drug substance part
of the vaccine, which is
kind of the active ingredient
of our vaccine products.
We'll be doing that in our
Durham, North Carolina facility.
Here at the West Point site,
we're responsible for the drug product.
- [Narrator] Dezura says
that after this facility
receives the frozen drug substance
from Johnson and Johnson,
the first step is to store
it here in this freezer room.
Trevor Brightwell is
the associate director
of vaccine operations at
the West Point facility.
- What you see here is
18 minus 70 C freezers.
This is where the drug substance bottles
will be stored upon receipt to the site.
- [Jared] Brightwell says
these freezers are all new,
brought in specifically
to store COVID vaccines
and each freezer holds 5.5 million doses
of the drug substance.
- Your typical freezer in your house
might be running at minus 10 degrees C.
These are running at minus 70.
And so with these types of products,
the colder that you can keep it,
it maintains the quality
of the drug substance.
- [Jared] When the drug
substance is ready to be put
in the vials, it is moved
to the filling facility.
Here, the drug is thawed and
then sent to the filling line,
where exact volumes of
the drug are dispensed
into glass vials and individually capped
and once they pass the
automated inspection,
they're transferred to the pack-out room.
- So we're in the very
final step of the process,
right before the product is
about to go out the door.
- Because vaccines are a
temperature-sensitive product,
it's important to minimize
their time out of refrigeration.
So, Merck developed this 3D printed tool
to help workers pack vials as quickly
and efficiently as possible.
This tool grabs 39 vials in one go,
so workers don't have to
load the vials one at a time.
After the vials are ready to go,
they are shipped back
to Johnson and Johnson
to handle the final
packaging and distribution.
Preparing for this operation
involved getting new equipment
and modifying its filling line
to accommodate the J&J vials,
all of which Merck says it
accomplished in less than a year.
How long does it normally get
ready to manufacture vaccines
and do this process?
- Typically, if we're
bringing in a new product
to a filling line, it
might take, you know,
a year or two to be able
to really go through
all the qualifications
and the transfer details.
- [Jared] Part of the reason
Merck says it was able
to adapt in just a few months,
was it's almost 60 years
of vaccine manufacturing experience.
- We have a long history
and a lot of different
types of vaccine products,
including you know, products
that are pretty similar
to the Johnson and Johnson products.
So, it really helped
us to be able to adapt
our current procedures quickly.
- [Jared] Another reason
is that Merck received help
from the U.S. government.
In March, the Department of
Health and Human Services
said it would spend $105 million
to help Merck upgrade its facilities.
- A typical part for a
filling line may take months
to receive and we were
able to turn that around
in sometimes days and weeks.
- [Jared] Dezura says Merck
plans to continue partnering
with J&J until the pandemic ends
or its manufacturing capabilities
are no longer needed.
- I think all of us have
been touched by the pandemic
and so the ability to really contribute
a potential solution for that
is, is just really remarkable.
(gentle instrumental music)